la actual constitución chilena que se
cambiara establece que el agua es
privada lo que no ocurre en ningún otro
país del mundo los chilenos pagan una de
las tarifas más altas de américa latina'
para consumir agua potable que en su
gran mayoría es propiedad de empresas
transnacionales
lo mismo ocurre con los recursos
minerales la constitución permite que
compañías privadas extranjeras extraigan
los bienes naturales que son un pilar de
la economía del país como el litio y el
cobre pero sin contemplar la
participación de industrias nacionales
ni del estado
y la actual constitución también habla
del estado subsidiario lo que significa
que el estado vigila a los particulares
que prestan los servicios de salud
educación o seguridad social pero no
provee directamente las prestaciones
para que los ciudadanos accedan a ellos
los servicios públicos de salud
educación y pensiones son calificados de
precarios en el país
precisamente por eso es que la
constitución era difícil de cambiar en
la carta magna- está determinado que
cualquier modificación debe contar con
el apoyo de dos tercios de los
legisladores tanto del senado como de la
cámara lo que hace que las
modificaciones sean muy difíciles de
aprobar todo eso fue lo que impulsó el
voto mayoritario para cambiar la
constitución pues gran parte de la
población chilena asegura que es
legítimo tener una carta magna heredada
de la dictadura y por eso cuando la
propuesta de una hoja en blanco para
trazar las nuevas reglas del juego